while the media house for the sidelines
today President Trump urged Democrats
get over their anger come to the table
watch this they were very very unhappy
with the Muller report no collusion no
obstruction no nothing they're very
unhappy they're angry about it they have
to get over their anger they have to get
over wait a minute they have to get over
their anger and they have to get into
infrastructure drug prices and things
like that
joining us now is Trump twenty20
national press secretary Kayleigh
mackaninee California Congressman Tom
McClintock and Republican strategist
Brad Blakeman we thank you all for being
here Kaley I'm gonna start with you
because I just have to giggle and they
think they're getting under that that's
the skin of Donald Trump are you kidding
me I think Donald Trump actually kind of
relishes them these kinds of of these
kind of skirmishes but what's your take
on it you're exactly right Jason it's so
funny to watch that record-breaking
times that someone could say under
president Trump's can it's as if the
Democratic National Committee just
emailed the talking points they all
printed them out and echoed them which
is exactly likely what happened here
it's quite the opposite though President
Trump gets under Nancy Pelosi skin he
gets under the Democrats skin Moeller
got under their skin when he completely
exonerated the president they are
totally triggered that's why you hear
impeachment that's why you hear their
bogus conspiracy theories he meanwhile
achieves at the fastest pace since
Ronald Reagan or faster than Ronald
Reagan if you read Heritage Foundation
so this president continues to succeed
he gets under Nancy Pelosi skin it's
incredible to watch no and Brad look the
Democrats are painting themselves in the
corner right they keep doing things I
don't know how they get out of these
coldest acts that they put themselves in
but how are Democrats going to play this
and how are you see this moving forward
then another player just like they did
with a mullah report remember they asked
for special counsel they got one and
then they said we believe in Muller and
we'll accept his findings they don't and
now they're continuing on this delusion
in order to create a atmosphere by which
they can take the president down it's
not enough to be against Trump you have
to beat him at the polls and you can
because you're not run
record Donald Trump has a record it
frustrates them to no end so it's not
them getting under the skin of Donald
Trump they are consumed by the fact that
Donald Trump has been successful in
spite of their efforts to get rid of
them now Tom McClintock and I served in
the Congress together I think we were
elected actually at the same time you
you're braver than I am to continue to
to sit there in the face of it
you're also a congressman from
California so you're very familiar with
Nancy Pelosi I still you go on the floor
of the house and try to listen to Nancy
Pelosi and what she's doing but what's
your read on what is she doing and how
is it that she's taking the positions
that she is well I love that term under
his skin he's the most thick-skinned
politician I've ever met he's got the
skin of an armadillo so I think they
flatter themselves if they think they're
getting under his skin I I think you
know one of two things is going on
either this is vintage Trump deals men
ship of reminds me of the scene from
Patton where Patton's ranting and raving
at the headquarters and one of his
agents pulls him aside and says general
you know sometimes the men don't know
when you're acting and George C Scott
playing Patton says it's not important
that the men know it's important that I
know so that might be what's going on or
it may be just pure human nature it's
you you can't amicably cooperate with
somebody who's trying to destroy you at
the same time and if that's the case the
Nancy Pelosi's got a pretty simple
choice she can either have a political
or a policy victory by getting together
on something like infrastructure or she
can keep nursing her political
grievances but she can't do both no I
think that's right and Kaleigh this is
the problem right Nancy Pelosi has a
meeting about impeachment in the
impromptu meeting then goes out and
accuses the president of violating the
law and that expects to sit down with
them in the next hour I mean I think
it's human nature to do what human with
Donald Trump did oh there's no doubt
about it this was a charade someone who
wants to in earnest negotiate and engage
in bipartisanship does not do any of the
things that you just named and likewise
if she wanted to
move forward with infrastructure there
was supposed to be another meeting where
Democrats laid out exactly what they
wanted and how they wanted to spend this
money well Nancy Pelosi cancelled it
we've seen it on every issue immigration
when President Trump proposed to daca
fix in exchange for the wall they
dismissed it we see it time after time
they're not earnest about this it's
politics they want impeachment and they
want to disenfranchise the American
people no and Brad I I got to tell you
it seems like Donald Trump should
actually be winning awards for his
openness and transparency and yet the
Democrats are claiming there's a
cover-up it's like when Donald Trump
does something they claimed the exact
opposite and it's so absurd their
position to say that he's covering
something up when he was about as open
as he possibly could in allowing all
this access to the special prosecutor
correct correct and not only that but he
instructed Attorney General Barr now to
go through literally thousands of
documents on that are classified in
order to have further transparency on
how this all got started and the
Democrats are beside themselves because
they never thought that the president
would respond the way he did
now we're gonna find out exactly what
was behind the dossier how it was
gathered the information and including
more information about the the treachery
that was happening at the senior
leadership of the FBI so my my caution
to Democrats is be be careful what you
wish for yeah congressman I've only got
30 seconds here or so but Adam Schiff is
saying that what the President did is
unamerican what's your read on it
no I think it's absolutely American
Louis Brandeis said it best sunlight is
the best of disinfectants it is now
becoming clear that we had the embryo of
a police state growing in our
intelligence agencies in our law
enforcement agencies and at the IRS IRS
preying on ordinary Americans because of
their political beliefs and the
intelligence agencies and the Department
of Justice at the highest levels
misusing their powers first to intervene
in our national election and when they
failed to do that to undermine the
constitutionally elected president of
the United States and we have to get to
the bottom of it
congressman McClintock one of the great
great people serving our country in
Washington DC we thank you for the
service and Kaylee and Brad thank you
again for joining us on this beautiful
Friday night thank you